once on the fringe the q anon conspiracy
theory has infiltrated the republican
party this year
we thought we'd take some time to
explain the movement how it got so big
and how it might affect our elections
looking forward to november
at its core q anon is an umbrella term
for a vast set of internet conspiracy
theories alleging the world is run by a
secret clique of satan worshiping
pedophiles that have control over
politics mainstream media
and hollywood the cabal is believed to
run a global child sex
trafficking ring that's plotting against
president trump
followers believe that high profile
individuals such as barack obama
hillary clinton george soros oprah
winfrey
pope francis and the dalai lama are all
involved
some believe that in addition to
molesting children
members of this ring eat their victims
to extract the life extending chemical
from their blood q and non believers
think president trump was recruited by
top
military generals to run for office in
2016 with the hope of breaking up the
cabal
this would end its control of politics
the media and put its members in prison
q anon first entered the online space in
when an anonymous user known as q began
posting on 4chan
this anonymous user claimed to have
knowledge of president trump's fight
against the global cabal
q anon believers wait anxiously for the
storm
the moment when president trump will
reveal members of the secret society
punish them and restore america to
greatness
the phrase this storm comes from a trump
press conference in 2017.
you guys know what this represents tell
us sir
it's still not clear what exactly the
president was referring to
not surprisingly q anon has spread in
popularity to the social media
and the kobe 19 pandemic according to
the wall street journal
q anon related facebook groups shot up
by 600
since the pandemic began twitter and
facebook have recently banned thousands
of accounts
but for years social media companies
allowed the theory to spread largely
untouched
there is even a reddit group for people
to mourn friends and family who have
lost themselves of theory
and becomes a so-called member of the q
anon cult
mike rothschild an author and expert on
conspiracy theories
says q continues to post but it's
sporadic
there have been about 4 700
q posts over the last two and two plus
years
q will go silent for a long time
sometimes in months and then
post like 50 posts in two days and some
of them are
like really complicated riddles and
codes and
pictures that are supposed to be of some
secret meeting
and some of them are just links to
tweets you know it's it's kind of
all over the place um you know
a lot of it is just sort of patriotic
nonsense
but then some of it is stuff that people
have really dug into and turned into the
sort of doctrine of this movement
president trump has refused to denounce
q anon
when he was asked by reporters about
kyunan recently
he said he did not know much about its
supporters saying quote
i heard that these are people who love
our country
and after he was told a summary of q
anon beliefs by a reporter
trump responded with quote is that
supposed to be a bad thing
yuan has transitioned from the online
world to the real world with some
believers being charged with violent
crimes
the fbi has labeled it as a potential
domestic terror threat
but the most recent milestone for the
movement is the victory of marjorie
taylor greene in a republican primary in
georgia
i have a message for antifa terrorists
stay the hell out of northwest georgia
president trump called her a quote
future republican star green has
promoted the conspiracy
many times and once labeled q a patriot
in a video q is a patriot we know that
for sure but we do not know who q is
she is likely to win election to
congress in november in her deeply red
district
earlier this year she was rebuked by
fellow republicans for posting facebook
videos
where she made disparaging remarks about
black people
jews and muslims green has since
attempted to distance herself from
kyunan
because she says q provided her
misinformation in 2018 about republicans
election prospects
rothschild says if more q a
non-believing politicians do
reach the halls of power and president
trump wins a second term
the message could see a major
amplification there's a lot of
members of congress that are fairly
anonymous but then you get some that are
on tv
all the time you would turn on fox news
and you're always seeing jim jordan mark
meadows
um you know these other sort of half a
dozen people and if one of the cube
believers becomes one of those people
and kind of stands down the really
really bizarre really lurid stuff
then i think this is going to get even
more mainstream and then i think we
we have a problem
you